Italy kicking up a fuss about Berlin's
migrant stance
Italy's interior minister Matteo salvini
has threatened to close his country's
airports if Germany goes ahead with
rumored plans to send migrants back on
chartered flights if anyone in Berlin or
Brussels is thinking of dumping dozens
of immigrants in Italy through
unauthorized charter flights they should
know there is not and will not be any
Airport available we will close the
airports like we closed the ports open
doors without limits and without rules
would lead to disaster is that so
difficult to understand criticize as
much as you want I will not stop the
situation highlights tensions between EU
states over how to deal with asylum
seekers Italy wants an automatic
distribution of migrants throughout the
European Union currently they are
required to stay in the country of entry
into the bloc Germany has already
returned at least 1600 migrants to Italy
in the first half of the year but Berlin
says it has no plans to send any
migrants in the coming days another rule
is that all migrants that are picked up
in the Mediterranean have to be taken to
Italy Rome thinks the EU regulations put
too much pressure on frontier States and
Italy and Germany are currently working
on a new agreement but it has yet to be
signed
[Music]
all the German politicians care about
currently is how their performance at
the next state election they don't care
about the situation in Italy they don't
care that you know the systems in Italy
do not have the resources to deal with
all the refugees they only care about
their own political game well the
easiest thing to do would be to take
care of the migrants in Germany and to
take good care of them instead of
putting them to Italy Germany has to
lead and not leave Italy alone
I think marbles era is over I don't
think any measure can save for anymore
it's too late
you